joe biden has given a speech on
primetime tv telling voters that former
president donald trump and his
supporters threaten their democracy the
midterm elections are in a couple months
they'll determine who controls the house
of representatives and senate
in his address biden accused trump
supporters of undermining the rule of
law and rolling back the rights and
freedoms of citizens
biden's democrats are only narrowly
ahead in opinion polls but issues like
inflation and abortion have upended the
political playing field here's more from
biden's speech
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not
normal
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
maggie republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people
they refuse to accept the results of a
free election
and they're working right now
as i speak in state after state
to give power
to decide elections in america to
partisans and cronies
empowering election deniers to undermine
democracy itself
maga forces are determined
to take this country backwards
backwards
to an america
where there is no right to choose
no right to privacy
no right to contraception no right to
marry who you love
and let's bring in u.s analyst peter
ladale this was joe biden like we've
never really seen him quite fiery and um
giving
trump and his supporters a real
thrashing
this was a biting us we haven't seen him
in a very long time
this is perhaps one of the most forceful
speeches i think we've seen him given as
president but also before there's a
candidate you know for the past three
years he's really tried to paint himself
as the uniter in chief as someone who's
decades of experience in the senate back
when he was a senator put him in a
position to you know reach across a
political aisle to make deal to get
things done after years of dysfunction
in washington um
for a long time he wouldn't even mention
trump by name he will call him the
former guy
so really not make it about trump but
make it about america and in this case
it seems like he is now waking up to the
fact that this is not the washington
that he came of h in uh it is a
washington where republicans have
blocked biden's agenda at every turn and
where republicans
as a party have also become more and
more extreme and where really the
loyalty to trump it seems uh comes above
all else um
you've seen whole after polls showing
that a sizable majority of republicans
as many as 70 percent still think that
biden is not the legitimate precedent um
where we've seen on the local level on
the state level on with the supreme
court that's also increasingly
conservative that
years that rights that americans took
for granted for decades have started
being rolling back from from abortion
through access to the ballot and and
maybe also at stake same-sex marriage so
that is the extremism we saw biden
warning against here very forcefully
biden said that this speech was about
the soul of the nation i want to play a
clip that i think really gets to that
point
we are still at our core a democracy
and yet
history tells us
the blind loyalty to a single leader
and a willingness to engage in political
violence is fatal to democracy
for a long time
we've told ourselves that american
democracy is guaranteed
but it's not
we have to defend it
protect it
stand up for it
each and every one of us
what do you make of that yeah this is
such an interesting part of the speech
and i think he's really trying to do two
things there on the one hand we see
biden trying to paint himself as the
penultimate commander-in-chief kind of
in the mold of a george washington
america's first president who led the
american army uh to victory during the
revolutionary narrative war um against
the british crown some 250 years ago and
biden here saying that you know we need
to stand up for the for democracy
he is the guy who is going to lead them
through that battle essentially right i
mean it's no coincidence that he's
giving this speech at independence hall
where the in philadelphia where the
declaration of independence uh was
written where the constitution was
written and so he's saying this is
really what is at stake here is either
going down the path toward tyranny
returning to what americans broke free
from some 250 years ago or continue on
the path of democracy and then we're
also seeing the second aspect which is a
a not so subtle nod i think to uh what
is going on
elsewhere in the world what we're seeing
in russia with a president vladimir
putin who is undoing uh what was left of
of democracy in russia the hungary where
we're seeing viktor orban
also on doing many of the things that we
associate with liberal democracies and
where there's just been a surge of
anti-democratic pro-authoritarian
movements throughout the continent so he
is both sending a message to americans
saying this is where we could behead it
but also you know a nod to the world
saying we're seeing you but to bring
this back to the u.s how do you think
the midterms will pan out it is a very
tough question one day in u.s politics
can can feel it can be a year in
in other places so we are beginning to
see the pendulum swing back in in
democrats favor and this is coming after
a you know after years of frustration
with biden who who
ran on being the guy who could get
things done in washington for a long
time he wasn't able to do that also
because of infighting among democrats
but we are seeing now that he scored a
significant amount of legislative
victories from infrastructure packages
to
tightening gun laws to
also we're just seeing basic things like
gas prices starting to come down and
those are things that really make a
difference to democrats and so
we're seeing a biden in a democratic
party i think who are looking at this
and saying this is how to beat not just
trump keep him away from the white house
in 2024 but also to beat republicans in
just three months